it happened I was influenced I got the
ninja creamy let's bring a protein ice
cream first up banana you can omit this
banana haters but let's be real protein
smoothies are always better with a
little banana scoop of protein powder
I'm going with chocolate today I'm doing
about 12 ounces of this Fair life milk
and a little bit of chocolate pudding
mix give it a little shaky shake and
then we put this in the freezer for like
12 hours
put it in
let's get the lid on and we twist and
I'm gonna put it on light ice cream
and if it looks a little crumbly like
this we're gonna add a little more milk
look at that now I like crunchy things
so I'm going to throw in some peanuts
and some freeze-dried strawberry
the little crunchy bits in there
what should I make in my ninja creamy
next